Pyron an all-star team is going to be
one of the most important things than
you ever do in your business because if
you have a big goal a big dream a big
vision you're trying to accomplish you
can't do that alone
you can't get there on your own you need
to have a team of people to help you
reach that dream and so many
entrepreneurs struggle with this because
you hire somebody and it doesn't work
out and you go back to thinking like I
got to do this myself because this just
isn't gonna work out so today I'm gonna
share with you my five fundamental
factors for hiring an all-star employee
those are gonna fly in the face of a lot
of traditional HR advice okay and the
reason is a lot of the traditional HR
advice is broken it doesn't work think
about the people that you've tried to
bring on board in your company by
following the traditional HR rules and
hiring processes how many of those
employees have worked out for you how
many first employees at companies ever
stick around it's almost zero because
the traditional methods are broken I'm
going to share with you what really
works so number one is stand for
something your company has to stand for
something meaningful there's something
important people don't want to come to
work just to earn a paycheck just to cut
code in front of a computer they want to
feel like they're contributing to the
world somehow that their presence at
your business is making the world a
better place it's important if you have
a job offer for a computer programmer or
you need somebody to do your website for
you they could go work for a hundred
different companies why are they gonna
pick you because your business means
something people don't go to work for
the salary they want meaningful work so
put that front and center you should
want to do something important to right
your company should stand for something
to make you happier to bring energy into
your business you should have people
lining up to want to come work with you
because of the powerful message that
you're putting out there
- believe you got to figure it out what
it is for your business when you have
that that's an instant way to stand out
so people aren't just comparing the
salary and the location the
to work for business that is doing
something important I had a customer
last night who bought my complete Zuger
package and he writes to me says Evan I
want to come work with you I want to
volunteer at your business tell me what
what you need help with I'll do it
I want to be a part of the team somehow
you should get that kind of reaction
consistently with your business you
should want people to be attracted to
you you're a magnet because you stand
for something important this is such an
important thing that most businesses
totally miss you need to stand for
something important that get people's
hearts and and soul into your company
instead of just paying them to show up
that's the difference so number one
stand for something
number two no resumes no cover letters
no interviews the traditional hiring
process I said is broken because what
you're hiring for the skill sets you're
hiring for if you want a computer
programmer I don't care how good you are
I created a resume I don't care how good
you are at doing an interview with me
one on one that's not what I'm hiring
you for right I don't need a programmer
who's amazing at doing interviews but
then sucks at actually programming you
want to hire for the skills that you
need and the process of going through
cover letter resume job interviews is
broken because this is how most
companies will do it right you post a
job ad you get all these resumes coming
in with cover letters right you're
reading through them if you get a
hundred applications and each one takes
you five minutes to read through that's
500 minutes of your time that's it
that's that's a huge amount of time
wasted for you when a lot of those
people don't even read the job
application properly did you see how a
computer programmer I'm gonna apply
takes them two seconds and it turns your
time out but then you go through that
process right okay I'm gonna weed them
out traditional HR process I'm gonna
weed them out we're gonna go through
interviews again days and days and days
of your time sorting through interviews
and finally you get the right person or
any think this this is the right person
we know we've vetted them we've checked
their references
they've interviewed with with you and
anybody else in your team your advisors
whoever finally the right person and
then you actually put them on the job
and how often does it actually work out
and you go through that three-month
trial period
so many people end up being fired or
quit in that process and you already
know within the first day and that's
gonna work or not but you've invested so
much into them into that whole process
of hiring that you are trying to find
and make it wait awake at work because
you don't want to go back to what it was
before you want to go and do that whole
painful process all over again so
eliminate the process and create a new
one that works for you I've made a video
about why the hiring process is broken
and how I use it you should check it out
it's a great resource but stop doing
resumes stop looking at covers letters
stop looking at interviews because those
are not the skills you're hiring for
number three hire passionate problem
solvers the number one ingredient that
you want in a new employee coming on is
someone who is passionate there's an
expression that you know I'd rather have
somebody who has ignorant on fire
instead of knowledge on ice you want the
person who is burning to be in your
business the person who will bust
through brick walls will solve any
problems right as an entrepreneur you're
running up against a million problems
every day right it's not a defined set
of problems it's gonna change as you
grow and build your empire and you need
people who will be resourceful and will
find solutions and people I've had on my
team me have had zero skills in the area
that now they're gonna get into but
they're willing to dive in I'll win
figure it out and not be told here's how
to do it
XYZ because they are passionate problem
solvers I've hired people who are there
total misfits they look terrible on
paper nobody would give these guys a
chance but they work hard they love what
they do they're committed to what my
business is all about
and they'll invest anything to go out
and find a way to make something happen
that's what you need so stop looking for
specific skills and look for people who
are passionate problem solvers because
often the guys who look the best on
paper end up being the worst employees
number four give opportunities to
explore there's nothing worse than
coming to a job and doing the same
thing over and over and over and over
and over and over again right would you
like that
that's why why you left your old job so
why are you being that kind of boss to
somebody else give people opportunities
to explore what they're good at what
they love because you are not the genius
of everything okay
you are not the expert at everything
give people a chance to explore what
they're good at
explore the creativity and bring that to
the business because they'll feel a lot
more fulfilled and you'll end up with a
much greater product than if you're just
slapping wrists and saying this is the
only exact way to do it so an example
that you guys can relate to I put out a
video not too long ago with the Beatles
success story and my initial vision was
to have you know the Beatles just their
video playing and me popping in texts
talking about their early struggles and
how they overcame them and Kristine I
was my video editor hey Christina
she she did that and then added her own
feel to it she added Beals pictures in
there and sometimes blocked out the
picture completely and and she made it
way better than what I had in my head
right I could have said no do it exactly
like this is the only way I want to do
it and wouldn't make Christina feel
restricted not happy but also we've had
a worse product right give people that
opportunity to explore the reason why I
hired Christina in the first place was
in that first job assignment that I gave
her and I gave 20 other people who are
applying to be my video editor she
didn't just do what I asked most people
just gave me what I asked right they did
the bare minimum they did they did what
I told him to do that's not good enough
she went beyond and she took the Vita
that I asked her to do it added some
Christina spice and magic to it like yes
the one person who did something
different who explored who pushed the
limits who thought of new ideas so I
don't have to do everything myself and
that's why I hired her and that's why
she's awesome and that's why she's still
working and going crazy making these
videos for us so you need to give people
that opportunity to explore and number
five make sure you have the time you
have to make sure you give yourself to
your team right there's nothing it's so
it's so bad when an employee comes to
work at the business and they're they're
thrown in they don't know what they're
doing they don't have the training they
can access you there's no way
connect with you really and there
they're feeling hopeless and a little
lost you got to make sure that when
you're bringing somebody on board you
free up your time to you will to train
them and answer their questions and
support them and when they're struggling
at the start be there guide them
motivate them remind them of what
they're doing right that that one-to-one
resource is huge and I know a lot of
entrepreneurs you know you're you're
running crazy businesses you're putting
in so many hours you know you're hiring
this person to take work away from you
now you gotta invest time into them you
may feel like you know I don't want to
do all that well if you're not willing
to invest in your team and be there for
them you have to be a great manager and
that seems not gonna love working for
you so especially at that start you got
to make yourself available you got to be
there to coach them and support them and
mentor them and teach them and train
them and don't just throw them to the
walls that will help you attract a lot
more of an all-star caliber employee
believe those you're watching like the
video you can subscribe to the channel
below and thank you so much I'll see you
soon make sure to check out my
newsletter ya got 11 hi I'm Jason G
responds Iike Rosalyn calm and I want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and it's the
only newsletter I prioritize and look
forward to period